il termine musica musica deriva dal
greco musica l'arte delle muse si
riferisce all'articolo le persone in
base a regole definite diverse a seconda
dei luoghi dell'epoca ma non basta un
insieme seppur e armonioso di suoni
perder vita la musica la musica nasce
cresce si sviluppa all'interno di un
determinato contesto sociale e ne
diviene manifestazione dello stesso
musica e rumore anticamente erano visti
come due cose contrapposte la musica non
poteva contenere il rumore rumore non
poteva contenere musica anticamente
perché esattamente un secolo fa qui a
milano nel 1913 luigi russolo creerà sei
famiglie di strumenti se famiglie di
strumenti that intonarumori con questi
strumenti russo lo crea creerà delle
composizioni fatte unicamente di rumore
il rumore di una città il rumore del
tram il rumore dell'aereo il rumore del
treno
il rumore di milano
all'esperienza di russolo seguiranno
direi diversi artisti che cominceranno
inserire nelle proprie composizioni il
rumore quindi misceleranno musica e
rumore edgar varèse george antheil piace
fell padre della musica concreta
cercando sempre un equilibrio tra i due
elementi ma nel secondo dipende
dopoguerra e si inserirà un nuovo
elemento che è il silenzio il silenzio
tenderà a staccare i suoni a staccare il
sony relativa alla musica e sono
relativi a tumore oppure vi saranno
artisti che daranno voce al silenzio
in particolare john cage
1952 john cage si siederà un pianoforte
lo chiuderà farà partire un cronometro 4
minuti e 33 secondi che il titolo della
sua composizione e rimarrà in silenzio
la composizione non sarà fatta di
silenzio bensì sarà fatto dei suoni
provenienti dalla sala il colpo di tosse
il bisbiglio in con nella prima sua
esibizione vi era la pioggia quindi
rumore del vento il rumore del temporale
gli artisti del secondo dopoguerra
guerra cercheranno sempre di spingersi
più avanti cercando sempre nuovi
equilibri in queste composizioni e a
partire dagli anni sessanta con la
nascita del genere rock vi saranno
artisti come jimi hendrix che
inseriranno nelle proprie composizioni
della distruzione distorsione della
chitarra elettrica che può essere intesa
sia come un rumore che come suono oppure
frank zappa cercherà di bissare
all'interno delle proprie composizioni
diversi generi musicali dal jazz al rock
alla musica classica ma proprio a
partire dagli anni sessanta in con il
genere rock e la musica avrà sempre più
maniera significativa il senso di un
veicolo di comunicazione gli artisti di
quel periodo cercheranno di trasmettere
come con la musica dei messaggi al
proprio pubblico è il pubblico considera
la musica come un momento di
aggregazione di scambio di idee
in particolare qui vediamo una foto di
woodstock
proprio in quel periodo cominceranno
anche ad essere utilizzati degli
strumenti nuovi strumenti che
permetteranno al compositore all'artista
di inserire suoni relativi come fece
russolo appena 60 anni prima relativi
all'ambiente socio economico o socio
culturale in cui essi vivevano ad
esempio i pink floyd
inseriranno nelle proprie composizioni i
suoni delle monetine o della cassa come
nel brano mani oppure inseriranno suoni
relativi al tempo
attraverso queste nuove strumentazioni
come il campionatore o il sintetizzatore
gli artisti avranno a disposizione degli
strumenti appunto che gli permetteranno
di controllare e modulare il suono di
creare nuovi suoni
nasceranno anche nuovi generi per
esempio i kraftwerk daranno vita a quel
filone che troviamo ancora tutt'oggi che
è quello della musica elettronica
e vi saranno artisti che negli anni
ottanta utilizzando questi suoni
inseriranno come aveva fatto russolo
appunto in precedenza dei suoni relativi
al loro periodo al come hanno fatto gli
art of noise che riprendono proprio il
nome da verso la ci sentiamo presi dente
il sound degli anni ottanta verrà invaso
da queste nuove sonorità e gli artisti
che partiranno appunto da questo periodo
andranno avanti come ad esempio i
depeche mode cambieranno il proprio
sound nel corso degli anni grazie anche
alle nuove strumentazioni nuovi suoni
che verranno ricondotti nelle loro
composizioni
come abbiamo detto però la musica è la
fotografia della società
così come essa si sta trasformando in
questi anni anche l'ambiente socio
culturale e socioeconomico a delle
significative trasformazioni
pensate che negli anni ottanta via il
passaggio dall epoca industriale a
quello posto industriale in particolare
in inghilterra grazie anche alla spinta
thatcheriana e proprio in inghilterra vi
sarà l'abbandono di intere fabbriche e
capannoni che verranno lasciati soli
abbandonati
fino a quando gli anni 90 o meglio dalla
fine degli anni 80 dei giovani
entreranno in questi capannoni per fare
delle feste per farci le concerti il
periodo revin da strati di dare vita a
questi capannoni con i suoni che li
avevano primi riempiti utilizzando anche
dei materiali che venivano utilizzate
l'industria lamiere barre di ferro
copertoni o materiale riciclato
siamo a circa un secolo dell'esperienza
di russolo è in ambito comunicativo si
fa sempre piacere la strada si fa sempre
più strada l'utilizzo delle immagini
associate al suono in particolare nel
2002 vi sarà una crew inglese i ninja
tune all'interno della stessa un gruppo
chiamato coldcut che metterà in piedi
uno strumento tale per cui riescono ad
abbinare emetterà tempo immagini e suoni
questo strumento verrà utilizzato per la
prima volta in un'esibizione al board di
parigi e successivamente nel 2006 in
audio live performance portata in giro
per il mondo
loro faranno conoscere al loro pubblico
questo brano timber con il quale
porteranno al loro pubblico la
problematica della della deforestazione
della foresta amazzonica in questo modo
questo immagina tratta proprio da loro
live quindi nel loro live loro ci si
vivano sia con mettendo utilizzarli
suona sia mettendo a tempo l'immagine
questo per un'ora e trenta di concerto
inoltre il suono diventa sempre più
significativo e identificativo di un
qualcosa se anticamente se o meglio se
in precedenza nel periodo di russolo era
il rumore che andava a
contraddistinguere un oggetto a partire
dall'anno 2000 e si fa sempre più la
strada in cui è l'oggetto essere
contraddistinto da un suono esempio a
gela spa 3 2001 dove il pubblico
riconoscerà con chiarezza il suono di un
cellulare ma non il cellulare qualsiasi
di una marca ben precisa
troviamo non temete smetta nessuno
dove
questo per quanto riguarda il cinema ma
anche nel campo automobilistico si è
prestata molta molta attenzione al suono
delle auto in particolare una piccola
casa automobilistica italiana a pagani
nel 2012 ha prodotto una macchina
l'avaria una macchina da 700 cavalli con
un motore biturbo secondo un motore
turbo non ha un motore così piacevole
per gli appassionati di queste vetture
che apprezzano più lui il suono di
motore aspirato hanno coinvolto degli
ingegneri del suono inglesi che assieme
agli ingegneri tedeschi hanno modificato
la sagomatura degli scarichi per dare un
rumore diverso all'auto ma altro esempio
è la tesla roadster la tesla produce
macchine elettriche in questo modello
del 2009 l'attesa non monterà nella
parte posteriore dell'auto due
altoparlanti per dare un suono all'auto
che sono ha dato ha dato il suono di una
macchina di un motore v8 o il suono da
guerre stellari
che senso ha dare una macchina un solo
da guerre stellari soprattutto una
macchina e così è voluta dal punto di
vista meccanico e tecnico quale può
essere una macchina elettrica
le case automobilistiche sono molto
attente ai dettagli sonori pensate
solamente alla strumentazione di bordo
ogni macchina il proprio sono oppure al
suono delle strumentazioni meccaniche la
chiusura di una porta oppure al sono
relativo alla comunicazione i sound logo
audi ha cambiato per tre volte in 14
anni il proprio sound loso facendo
evolvere in questo modo
questa è l'evoluzione in termini di
suono ma attualmente vi è sempre più la
attenzione all'abbinamento tra sona
immagine
ciò non è sempre efficace ed efficiente
pensate degli spot televisivi molte
volte ricordate il motivo o la marca ma
non ricordate il prodotto o il messaggio
promozionale
eppure vi sono artisti che riescono a
coniugare perfettamente suono e immagine
dando al pubblico un effetto come questo
e in pochissimi casi vengono utilizzati
anche nell'ambito della comunicazione
that mouse un paio di anni fa per il
lancio del nokia lumia a londra ha fatto
questo spettacolo incredibile
coinvolgendo l'intera città in questo
modo
2013 100 anni dall'esperienza di rosso
cosa è cambiato
nel periodo di russolo vi era l'arte del
rumore a oggi abbiamo l'arte del suono
siamo ormai invasi da suoni e lo saremo
sempre di più è necessario
razionalizzare
organizzarle puntare ad esempio a
mettere ordine in questo universo
selvaggio sonoro anche utilizzando
risorse interne nostro paese e 80mila
autori ad esempio 2000 editori non
abbiamo una storia millenaria
quindi vi partendo dall'esperienza di
lusso e facendo
perno su quell'esperienza e ripartire e
dare nuovo slancio a questa nuova
attività di organizzazione del suono
lavorare sullo stesso è lasciare da
parte ormai la vecchia esperienza legata
a rumore per ripartire una nuova
esperienza legata al suono come come
hanno fatto tutti gli artisti che hanno
seguito russo credendo nel mix